I appreciate that that's very kind of
you pleased I like it to go on all night
but this as always with Donald Trump
there's just too much news to get to I
mean this administration happens in like
dog years you know I mean there's so
much [ __ ] crazy it's like three weeks
of Trump is like five years of Nixon but
you know what this was a good week to
the resistance this was a good week for
checks and balances a good week for me
may be surviving president man-baby
because of federal appeals court
unanimously rules against his Muslim ban
which means refugees from Syria Iraq
Iran Yemen Libya Sudan Somalia a once
again free to come here and be Ober
drivers yeah how about that
turns out a law isn't just something
Steve Bannon writes on a napkin
and Donald from signs while making his
smart face so Trump is now lost twice in
court if we found out this week his
closest advisor Kellyanne Conway at his
National Security Advisor Mike Flynn or
be investigated for ethical misconduct
they told Donald Trump today that his
wall his beautiful walls going to cost
twice as much that he thought it's
almost like he's losing so much he's
tired of losing it that and you know
this is a guy who takes losing well
doesn't he yeah when the ruling came
down from the court he was like Oh see
you in court
see you in court their judges of course
you're going to see them in court like
saying hey Chris Christie I'll see you
at the Cheesecake Factory
a party there's so much you know how
about this one Sean Spicer his press
secretary will not confirm or deny that
he is considering Sarah Palin to the
ambassador of Canada he says it'll take
her a while to learn the language but
we're safe and it goes smoothly after
that I mean other countries are
literally rolling their eyes I mean that
literally Trump met today with the
Japanese Prime Minister and he held his
hand for a handshake for 18 seconds
until yeah look there we go
that says it all back and to the right
back and to the right I mean what do we
tell other countries America is under
new management it's like you ever pull
into a Holiday Inn in a rainstorm and
you think it's a Holiday Inn but no now
it's a have a stay in and there are
hookers in the lobby and crime scene
tape and black mold and the remote
smells like Lube
that's American
[Applause]
but you will be glad to know that the
president finally got down to the issue
that's really plaguing America which
retailers are carrying a bunkers closing
line now if you didn't know about this
Donald Trump's daughter wife Ivanka she
had a just a clothing line which was
dropped by department stores including
Nordstrom of course Trump went apeshit
on Twitter about this you know what of
all the people mr. businessman shoot he
should understand they dropped it
because the merchandise just wasn't
moving the only one interested in
getting into Ivanka's pants is M
and then of course he had poor Sean
Spicer go up there and say this is a
direct attack on the president's policy
and his family and it's not accepted
okay first of all it's not an attack on
his policy and if it was so what is it
free country I don't work for Donald
Trump we have to buy his kids Girl Scout
cookies and then Kellyanne cotton it
goes on Fox News and says go buy Ivanka
stuff go buy it everybody well first of
all the joke's on you
Ivanka doesn't make Fox viewers a size
xxx but also this is patently illegal
for a federal employee to so go buy a
product from I mean now liberals are
chanting lock her up lock her up
and you know Trump voters of course now
are boycotting Nordstrom all of Trump
friends are lining up behind him for
this
Vladimir Putin today he's going to buy
all his poison that may seem ridiculous
but but you know I mean in his Nordstrom
tweet it happened during the
intelligence briefing we notice he's
getting the intelligence briefing and
he's tweeting about this that's the
president we have now ladies and
gentlemen enough about the Middle East
what's the latest on women's
ready-to-wear but the president if North
Korea gets ahold of that plutonium shut
up I'm writing a yelp review
but here's the thing that pissed me off
the most this week did you see this
Mitch McConnell told Elizabeth Warren to
sit down and shut up
right okay he said she was warned she
persisted yeah that's a mean now and
then he pulled some ancient
Congressional rule out of his turtle ass
and said you can't accuse another
senator of conduct unbecoming a senator
but that's not what Elizabeth Warren was
doing she just read a letter from
Coretta Scott King that was super
pertinent to the case she was making
against confirming Jeff Sessions this is
supposed to be the world's most
deliberative body but Mitch McConnell
needs a safe space with a speech code so
your microaggressions doesn't trigger
his hurt feelings whiny little [ __ ]
nothing has changed that's what they are
whiny little [ __ ] and Donald Trump
nordstrom tweet he said my daughter
Ibaka's been treated so unfairly she's a
great person
she's always pushing me to do the right
thing hey Ivanka push harder
[Applause]